Let's do a couple of warm up
problems converting fractions
to percentages and
then converting
percentages to fractions.
And then we can do some
actual word problems.
So on our first warm up, let's
convert 5/24 to a percentage.
And the way I like to do it,
I like to convert it to a
decimal first. And once you have
it in the decimal form,
it's pretty straight forward to
convert it to a percentage.
So the way you convert to a
decimal is you divide the
denominator into
the numerator.
This can, literally, be read
as 5 divided by 24.
So let's do a little
bit of division.
24 goes into 5.
And we're going to have to add
some extra spaces to the 5
because, obviously, this is
going to be less than 1.
24 is a larger number then 5.
So let's put our decimal
right there.
And we can now do
some division.
24 goes in to 5 zero times.
0 times 24 is 0.
5 minus 0 is 5.
Bring down this 0 right here.
24 goes into 50.
Well it goes into
that two times.
2 times 24 is-- 2
times 4 is 8.
2 times 2 is 4.
Now we subtract.
50 minus 48 is 2.
Bring down another 0.
We're going to keep
bringing down 0's
until we have no remainder.
So bring down another 0.
24 goes into 20 zero times.
0 times 24 is 0.
20 minus 0 is 20.
Let's bring down another 0.
24 goes into 200-- let's
see, eight times?
It'd be nine times?
It's 180.
No it'd be eight times,
I believe.
Let's see if eight
times works.
There's always a little
bit of an art to this.
If this is too little, we might
have to increase it.
8 times 4 is 32.
8 times 2 is 16 plus 3 is 19.
No, that was right.
Eight times.
200 minus 192, that's 8.
That is 8.
Bring down another 0.
24 goes into 80 three times.
Can't be four times.
3 times 4 is 12.
Carry the 1.
3 times 2 is 6.
Add 170 and then you
have another 80.
You bring down another 0.
We have infinite supply of
0's here as we need them.
And we're going to
have another 80.
Well once again, 24 is going to
go into that three times.
And we're going to start
repeating these 3's over and
over and over again.
So 5 over 24-- let me
write this down.
5 over 24-- I want
you to understand
why it keeps repeating.
Every time we do this now,
we're going to get a 3.
And come down, get a 72.
80 from 72, we're going to get
another 80, and we're just
going to have a big string
of 3's there.
So 5 divided by 24 is
0.2083 repeating.
Now, if we want to write this
as a percentage, the word
percentage-- the word percent.
Let me split it up.
Per cent.
Cent comes from the
word for 100.
This is per 100.
So what is this?
This is 0.20.
What is this per 100, where
100 is a whole?
And that might confuse
you or it might not.
But one way you can do this is
this is the same thing as--
you could do it this way.
This is the same thing.
This decimal 0.2083 repeating
is the same thing as 20.83
repeating over 100.
This is how many we
have per 100%.
Or you could say that this is
equal to 20.83% per 100.
These are equivalent.
A very quick way to think about
how to go from decimals
to percent is you can multiply
by 100, and then put the
percentage sign.
Or, if you go backwards, you
divide by 100 and get rid of
the percentage sign.
That was a good warm up.
Let's do one more.
Let's convert a percentage
into a fraction.
I'll do it in blue.
So let's say we have 16%.
Remember this means
16 per 100.
So this is the same thing
as 16 per 100.
That's what per cent--
century is 100 years.
There are 100 cents
in a dollar.
So 16 over 100.
Put that in the lowest-- let's
see, you can divide the
numerator and the denominator
by 4.
We get 4 over 25.
So that's our warm up.
Let's do some actual
problems now.
All right.
They tell us a TV is
advertised on sale.
It is 35% off, and has
a new price of $195.
What was the pre-sale price?
So if x is the pre-sale price,
when you take 35% off of that,
it has a new price of $195.
So x minus 35% of x-- 0.35
is the same thing as 35%.
So if I take x and I subtract
35% of x from x, I'm
going to get $195.
That's what that
is telling me.
So now we just solve for x.
So you can view this
as 1x minus 0.35x.
That will be 0.65x.
So this is 0.65x, right?
If you add 0.65 and
0.35, you get 1.
1 minus 0.35 is 0.65x
is equal to 195.
And now you can divide both
sides of this equation.
Actually, I like to do it more
as a fraction, so let me write
it that way.
So if you have 65 over 100x is
equal to 195, now we can
multiply both sides of this
equation by the inverse.
Actually, even before
I do that, let me
simplify this fraction.
I can divide the numerator
and denominator by 5.
This becomes 13 over 20.
So we get 13 over 20x
is equal to 195.
And now we can multiply both
sides by the inverse of this.
So 20 over 13 times that is
equal to 195 times 20 over 13.
These cancel out, and we get x
is equal to 195 times 20 over
13, which we could figure out,
but I'll take the calculator
out for this one.
So let's see.
You get 195 times 20 divided
by 13 is equal to $300.
I should have done that-- so
this is equal to-- that right
there is equal to $300.
So $195 is actually
divisible by 13.
I should be able to do that
without a calculator.
Anyway, so the original
price was $300.
You take 35% of $300, which
is $105, and you will
be left with $195.
So that was our original
price.
Let's do another one.
An employee at a store is
currently paid $9.50 per hour.
If she works a full year, she
gets a 12% pay raise.
What will be her new hourly
rate after the raise?
So today, she makes 9.50.
If she works for 12 years,
she'll make 9.50 plus 12%.
Let me write this way;
plus 12% times 9.50.
That's how much her
raise will be.
So her new hourly rate will
be this entire thing.
Well, we could view
it this way.
This is the same thing as 9.50
plus 0.12 times 9.50.
This is the same thing
as 1 times 9.50
times 0.12 times 9.50.
So this is the same
thing as 1.12.
I'm just adding that.
Let me do this in a
different color.
I'm just adding that and that
to get that, times 9.50.
We are growing 9.50 by 12%.
You already have the 9.50
plus another 12%.
It's 1.12 times 9.50 is going to
be equal to our new number.
Let me multiply this just to
make up for me using the
calculator the last time.
So 9.50 times 1.12.
2 times 0 is 0.
2 times 5 is 10.
2 times 9 is 18 plus 1 is 19.
And I'll put a 0 here.
1 times 0 is 0.
1 times 5 is 5.
1 times 9 is 9.
Let's put two 0's here.
1 times 0 is 0.
1 times 5 is 5.
1 times 9 is 9.
And now we can add.
The 0's add up to 0.
9 plus 5 is 14.
2 plus 9 is 11 plus 5 is 16.
1 plus 9 is 10.
And then we count the
number of decimals.
We have one, two, three, four
numbers behind the decimals.
So in our answer, we have to
have one, two, three, four
numbers behind the decimal.
So her new salary will
be $10.64 per hour.
$10.64.
You don't have to write those
trailing 0's right there.
So this is her new hourly
rate after the raise.
All right.
Let's do one more.
Store A and store B
both sell bikes.
And both buy bikes
from the same
supplier at the same price.
Store A has a 40% mark-up.
That means whatever they buy the
bike for, they sell it for
40% above that.
While store B has
a 250% markup.
Store B has a permanent sale,
and always will sell at 60%
off those prices.
Which store has a better deal?
So let's say that they're both
buying the bikes, so x is
equal to the price
from supplier.
So that's the price that
both bike stores buy
their bicycles at.
They both buy bikes from the
supplier at the same price.
That's this x that I'm going
to start off with.
Now lets do the scenario
of store A.
What does store A sell
their bike for?
They sell the bike for x plus
40% of x, which is equal to
1.4 times x.
That's how much store A
sells their bike for.
Now store B is a little
bit more interesting.
Store B-- so they have
a 250% markup.
Well, they claim to sell their
bike for x plus 250%.
That's the same thing
as 2.5 times x.
A 100% markup would literally
mean another x.
This is 250%.
And as we said, you can
just divide by 100.
You get 2.5.
Get rid of the percentage
sign.
So they sell it x plus 2.5x,
which is equal to 3.5x.
That's kind of their
ticket price.
But then, they sell at
60% off those prices.
So then they take 60% off of
this price right here.
So the real selling price is
going to be 3.5 times the
price from the supplier
minus 0.6.
Minus 0.6.
Minus 60% of this price.
Of 3.5x.
And we could view this
as 1 times 3.5x
minus 0.6 times 3.5X.
And that's the same thing as
1 minus 0.6 times 3.5x.
This is going to be 0.4.
This is 0.4.
So if you're taking 60% off,
it's the equivalent of selling
it at 40% of the ticket price.
That's what we're doing
right there.
You might, eventually, do this
in your head-- immediately
say, oh, 60% off is the same
thing as selling at 40%, or
selling at 0.4 of the price.
3.5x.
And let's multiply that out.
So if we take 3.5x times
0.4, 4 times 5 is 20.
4 times 3 is 12 plus 2 is 14.
And we have one, two numbers
behind the decimal spot.
Two numbers.
One, two.
1.4.
So they're going to
sell it at 1.4x.
So in either store, you
actually going to
pay the same price.
Let's say they buy the bikes
from the supplier at $100.
Then at store A, you're going to
pay $140 for that bike, and
in store B, you're going to
spend $140 for that bike.
But in store B, you think
you're getting 60% off.